[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the 33rd dark horse podcast
live stream i am here with dr heather
heing
um lots of things are occurring i think
we should get right
to it all right all right let's
go ahead so i was good you we talked
about um he's setting up some of what
we've been
uh discussing and then launching into a
conversation about
same should we do that should we start
there yeah how about i set up your setup
okay okay this is like the english to
english translation oh man it's it's
just right on target for english to
english translation so what's what's
happening here
is that i had
what seemed to me like an epiphany last
night and i explained it to heather and
she said that's everything we've been
talking about
what's there and we wrestled about this
for a while and it turned out she was
absolutely right and there was stuff
that needed to be
brought to the surface in order to find
what was new and so anyway
well i think but then therefore i wasn't
absolutely right because there is
something new here
uh i i wasn't seeing it at first i don't
know how much of that is because you
weren't saying it at first and
how much was because it felt like it was
the same stuff and slightly different
clothing
well let's put it this way um the nature
of uh consciousness and discovery and
emergence being what it is
um i think i was not saying it in such a
way that what was new
i did have the inkling of something new
but i hadn't figured out what it was
and um so anyway i think a very normal
process of wrestling something into some
kind of useful form
occurred and uh anyway and zach got to
witness the whole thing
toby our other son left at some point
cleaned up after dinner and
slunk away well he can watch the live
stream uh either now or later
that's right all right so should we
should we launch into it let's do it
okay so we this
to the position that we currently find
ourselves in in society
uh we wanted to start by saying two
things
not axiomatic exactly but two things
that are true in a number of situations
what the background of our current
environment is
and then the current situation with
regard to the protests and riots and the
streets
um so i'm going to set all that up and
then we'll then we'll talk more and
we'll have a little cat bell throughout
a little bit of cat bell yeah a little
cowbell so the first two things that um
that we that we know to be true across
uh a number of domains not at all
limited to
right now are that ponzi scheme ponzi
schemes exist
also known as pyramid schemes uh and
they carry a pattern of behavior from
one individual to an exponentially
expanding number of individuals
until they collapse and the usual
incentive of course
is currency accumulation like actual
literal
dollars and that functions within the
system as long as the layers below you
exist those who are effectively feeding
you their currency have to exist or else
you don't you know join so that's one
thing right we have pyramid schemes so
pyramid schemes
collapse on the late adopters exactly
so they are not a fiction from the point
of view of early adopters the fiction
comes from the idea that it can continue
to function yep the second thing that is
uh that is true across many domains but
highly relevant to
this situation we find is a
idea formalized by naseem teleb
in a piece well in his incerto in a
piece that he calls the most intolerant
wins the dictatorship of the small
minority
so just to quote him the best example i
know this is tele
writing the best example i know that
gives insights into the functioning of a
complex system is with the following
situation it suffices for an
intransigent minority
a certain type of intransigent
minorities to reach a minutely small
level say three or four percent of the
total population
for the entire population to have to
submit to their preferences
further an optical illusion comes with
the dominance of the minority
a naive observer would be under the
impression that the choices and
preferences are those of majority
if it seems absurd it is because our
scientific intuitions aren't calibrated
for that
forget about scientific and academic
intuitions and snap judgments
they don't work and your standard
intellectualization fails with complex
systems
though not your grandmother's wisdom so
we have pyramid schemes the existence of
pyramid schemes and the existence of
this
this truth that many people do not
intuit especially those who
think they like to play in numbers but
actually are kind of enumerate
the idea that actually a tiny tiny
percentage he puts it at three to four
percent can actually be sufficient
to convert an entire system add to this
the background situation of just social
media which is a kind of online
ecosystem which can house its own ponzi
schemes
and features include trafficking in a
kind of
social currency as opposed to monetary
currency
which is quantified in ways that we can
all see you know followers and likes and
subscribers and views which you know
we're playing in that landscape here and
of course in social media the product
evolves culturally by very standard
cultural evolution mechanisms just to
add a few more things to the setup
before we
we go further with it together uh the
current situation with regard to the
protests
and now riots on the streets with regard
to the movement that is formally called
black lives matter
although many of the people who are
advocating for change on the streets
don't know what that movement actually
stands for
note that uh only to teleb's point with
regard to
the um dictatorship of the small
minority only a tiny group of people
could actually believe
and this was your opening salvo to me
last night only a tiny percent of people
could actually believe
that it would be a good idea to abolish
the police or
that logic is a function of whiteness
which are two of the things that are
being
being said um that's
and yet and yet it's gaining ground okay
so add two more things
and then we'll we'll engage we'll engage
with
each other in the cat here we have a
public relations issue that is different
from most ponzi schemes
in that while many people have never
heard abolish the police or logic as a
function of whiteness
they believe that they're fighting the
next civil rights fight
um they think they're being righteous
they think that they are actually
fighting for
change that is not what the intransigent
intransigent minorities
is advocating for uh and then finally
there's a payload here there is there it
this is not
just about being able to make a little
cash off the
off the backs of the people who follow
in the pyramid scheme
uh the payload in this particular one
has the chance to actually take over and
frankly destroy civilization
right it may be able to restructure the
real world and not just the online world
so let's unpack this a bit yeah the idea
what started the discussion last night
was
that nobody could possibly believe this
that the number of people who actually
believe
as you said that eliminating the police
would be a good idea that it would
increase
the safety of the public is tiny if you
then
figure okay well what's the percentage
of people who might think that
opening the borders would be a good idea
all right also tiny
right so what do you mean like
abolishing the borders opening the
borders open borders
yeah what is the fraction of people who
think it's a good idea
to abolish prisons right now you take
the intersection of these things
what are the chances that you believe
all of these things right this movement
at various times espouses all these
things now take what
what percentage of the population thinks
that the nuclear family
is somehow a mechanism of white
oppression of other people
right the intersection is a fraction of
a percent
at most right people don't actually
believe this stuff it's too dumb
but it is now threatening to alter
policy and so the question is how did
that
happen how does the tiniest of
minorities end up
dictating terms to society terms that
will ultimately
cause the collapse of civilization if
they are
broadened right why is it that in
seattle
we are apparently discussing um the
abolition
of prisons and police simultaneously i
mean even if you were dumb enough to
think that those were a good idea
you would want to figure out whether
they were a good idea together
in other words you're going to open the
you're going to abolish the prisons
do you believe that psychopaths exist
are there any in prison i think they're
actually pretty likely to end up there
right so you're gonna release some
psychopaths
is it possible you might want more
police in that case you don't know
but the point is however dumb it is to
abolish the prisons it would be even
dumber to do it as you defunded or
eliminated or abolished or whatever your
terminology is
the police and yet we are discussing
these things
um we have the mayor of la
broadcasting on twitter his solidarity
with the uh protesters in portland now
frankly i went to school with the mayor
of l.a i didn't know him well but i did
go to school with him
before he was the mayor oh quite a bit
before he i think he was a few grades
below me but
in any case um to have the mayor of los
angeles
broadcasting a message of support for
people that i believe are putting
the rule of law in jeopardy in my
hometown
is a remarkable turn of events right how
could somebody
have ended up in such a position of
power and
be persuaded by such low quality
arguments and so
in any case where we arrive is that
actually this isn't about persuasion
this is about a ponzi scheme in which
you don't uh well let's put it this way
the mayor of l.a has apparently signed
up for this ponzi scheme
and he's signed up early enough that
maybe it doesn't collapse on him and he
seems to be okay with the idea that
it might collapse on portland and that
it might
result in violence against people that
he doesn't know or doesn't care about or
whatever it is so
the point is a ponzi scheme actually
ponzi was a guy
the ponzi scheme started with one person
right now maybe critical theory isn't
one person
it may be a small discipline of people
who believe amazingly foolish things
but they are managing to spread those
things not by virtue
of the arguments being the least bit
compelling but by two mechanisms
one of them is that you are better off
signing on
and letting it collapse on other people
so standard ponzi scheme
uh stuff but um also by virtue of the
fact that we have this evolutionary
phenomenon taking place
online right you have the
characteristics necessary for adaptive
evolution on twitter facebook everywhere
else which is you have
reproduction you have variation you have
heritability and differential success
and say it again those four that's
what's needed reproduction
you've got variation the variation is
heritable
and you've got differential success
which means that the messages
are evolving now i want you to ask
yourself a question
do you know why it is that we mustn't
open the borders
can you explain it you probably can't
you know we shouldn't
you know it would be a terrible idea but
the problem is unless you have the
language of game theory unless you have
at the
tip of your tongue the phenomenon of a
tragedy of the commons
it's very hard to explain why that would
be a bad idea and
who will be harmed by it it happens that
if you open the borders you can predict
the following thing
people who flood over the borders
because there is opportunity here more
so than
elsewhere they are not going to take
corporate jobs
whose jobs are they going to take
they're going to take
the lower wage jobs the lower skilled
jobs right so who is going to get hurt
by what floods over the border right
it's going to be people who are
most disadvantaged not the people who
are at the top of this ladder
so it's a very uh it's a very regressive
move
to expose the lowest rung of the ladder
to intense competition from people
flooding over the borders
however it is very hard to explain why
you mustn't open the borders without
then opening yourself to the accusation
that you were anti-immigrant
right and i mean i think when you were
talking about the idea of
abolishing prisons and that
you know if if that was successful that
would likely result in the actual need
for more police because you would have
actual psychopathic criminals which is
hardly the entire population
of prisons but it almost certainly
represents a higher population of
prisons than out in the rest of the
world
abolishing prisons would require more
police in order to keep people safe but
these two moves are happening at the
same time
abolish prisons these two movements
abolish prisons and abolish police
and it reminded me actually of the um
i want to imagine unintended consequence
but at the time
it seemed insane in the 80s
when reagan basically went after a lot
of mental health hospitals
closed them down shunted a bunch of
people with actual mental health
problems onto the streets and boom we
get a rise in homelessness
and there was there were no there were
no things put in place to accommodate
these people who had no ability to help
themselves because they had just been
thrown out onto the street
yeah it's a very good analog we've got
the population
that can't fend for themselves because
of mental disorders
and then here we've got a population of
people who won't play by the rules
because
they're not built for it now as you
point out we immediately step into this
trap
right oh you want to keep the prison
industrial complex
well no i don't i'm police reform
prison reform mental health reform we we
are not claiming that any of this is
being done right
food reform like almost none of our
modern systems are being done right and
this
you know this is something we've been
this has been our
our bread and butter our wheelhouse for
decades now and is in fact
what our book is about you know what is
it that we should be eating that we're
not doing how should we be sleeping that
we're not doing how
is the hyper novel environment of the
21st and late 20th century
destroying human life everything from
relationship and childhood
to school back to food and sleep and
health and medicine
on to society and how to be an adult it
then hyper novelty is destroying all of
it
and part of what we have now is a
a empowered minority tiny minority
who know that change is necessary and
are being handed solutions that aren't
solutions and all they can do is shout
those things
abolish the police abolish prisons no
that's not
going to work it's not going to work and
people who say that's not going to work
are not
inherently conservatives you and i are
you know lifelong
liberals we are progressives and you
know i don't
i don't know where you would put
yourself but i would say i'm a radical
because i believe we need radical change
that is not the same thing as all change
is good
maximal change is good right well this
is down
this is another one of the linguistic
traps that is set right well we have a
uh we the movement the protesters
whatever
are going to claim a goal and
if you do not sign on with that goal
then clearly you are
anti whatever you know you are
you are against us um but snuck into
that
is we have methods and you have to not
only sign on with the goal but in order
to sign with the goal you have to sign
on with our methods
and we have seen four years now over and
over and over again that the methods
are often actually maybe designed
maybe inadvertently often some
combination of the two but the methods
will actually achieve the opposite of
the stated goal
therefore when you stand against the
methods of many of these movements you
were actually saying
no i do believe black lives matter i am
anti-racist
and you are acting in a way that is the
opposite of that
but by standing against a movement that
has cleverly branded itself it's
basically won the pr
game we appear to be the people who
are regressive when it's actually quite
the opposite yeah now i'm going to push
back a little bit on this question of
methods because
i find that the methods thing is
a retreat that people who
can't find the courage to object to
obviously stupid and dangerous things
go to and they force us to it by saying
so you agree with the objective
but you don't agree with the methods
then right and my feeling is
the problem is with a leaderless
movement what you don't have is any
ability to say what they are
actually pursuing and some of the people
pursuing this are
actually not well intentioned and so the
point is
no that's not an i disagree with the
idea that we should be even listening to
these people
let alone correcting them about methods
the majority of people
who are sympathetic in some way have
some
vague idea right but the basic point is
evolution has created a set of arguments
that
dumb as they are are very difficult to
challenge
how did that happen our online
environment has created a
new mode for the evolution of discourse
and it explains a great deal about what
we are seeing it explains
what is i hate the term but being called
cancel
culture right cancel culture is
about the evolution of mechanisms
to tear down something that stands in
your way
right how is that evolving well lots of
people are experimenting with arguments
and when something goes viral when some
argument catches on
boom that thing becomes the new argument
and that process that evolutionary
process
builds this bulwark of nonsense
that is nonetheless difficult to
challenge and so those of us who know
better
are busy saying well i don't i don't
understand
even why we have to establish that for
example
men and women are different right i
don't understand how we
fell to a level where that actually
needs some kind of a defense
and as you pointed out last night there
was a
standard that applied when we taught
college students how to
make proper scientific arguments you
want to say what it was yeah no
when i was when i was teaching people
how to write scientific papers
and you know the question would always
would always come up which is a totally
legitimate question and one that most
people haven't considered formally
what do i cite when do i reference
something that i've written down
and you know the answer is it is a
judgment call
and if it's entirely your own idea you
don't cite it and that is part of why
you must cite every idea that is not
yours and that is new
so that the reader can know that when
you aren't citing something that's your
idea newly
but what you don't cite you cite
anything that is new enough
to be attributable to a person or a
research program
but once things have become so accepted
within the dominant scientific culture
and that's not to say that some things
couldn't be overturned but once things
become so accepted within the dominant
scientific culture
you do not cite them we no longer have
to cite
galileo or
darwin right when we when we speak to
the very important observations and
truths
that they revealed to all of us and in
part the reason that we know who those
people are
is uh is testament to why we no longer
have to cite them because they were so
those were such um universal and
enduring truths
so you don't occasionally in this you
know men are women and women aren't men
argument um i will receive well you know
show us your receipts show us the
citation
and you know no no one is writing this
because there's no
it's just it's just been understood
accurately for cautions the greeks
before that and that the men aren't
women and that women
aren't men and i can point to papers
that suggest
that 1.2 billion years ago sex evolved
and that about 500 million years ago our
lineage
started going down a path of sexual
reproduction that's uninterrupted
but that's not a citation that says
men and women are different right that
doesn't exist in the scientific
literature because it's not true
wouldn't know who to cite yeah i mean it
doesn't exist i wouldn't know who to
cite wouldn't know
you know it's too obvious and so the
point is yes this is just another trap
can you explain why you don't have a
citation
that explains that men and women are
different well no i can't exactly
explain that but it's hardly an
indictment
right so one one thing um with regard to
this this particular pyramid scheme
um that makes use of this intransigent
intransigent minority
in televised words to make a tiny
minority position
appear to be the majority is that um
you know many pyramid schemes are are
basically opt-in you get approached
and there's this external motivator and
external motivators tend to be either
carrot or stick and this is part of why
external motivation is not nearly as
effective or
honorable as internal motivation but
external motivators tend to be character
stick
and a typical pyramid scheme is using uh
the carrot
of your own greed right your own greed
for wealth
and and therefore you know when it's
carrot it can be opt-in
be like come come to the carrot but
these
this one here it seems to be opt out
and it's using the stick it's using fear
it's using the fear of being hurt if you
don't succumb if you don't get in line
as the way that it motivates people to
join and it's not even
it there's an opt-out component but um
are we opted out
i mean it seems to me we've got live
stream after live stream talking about
the fact that we are not on board with
this thing but we cannot affect
the fact that the mayor slash police
commissioner of our city
has decided not to enforce
the law locally and the new york times
has decided to portray
federal action to enforce the law around
federal buildings
as a fascist incursion so
we are being set up right so
as much as we would like to opt out we
can opt out of
the narrow thing of participating in
spreading the ponzi scheme
but we cannot opt out of its
consequences they have opted everybody
in and so
what i think needs to be understood
is nobody has any idea what fraction
of the population of seattle actually
organically believes
that abolishing the police and
abolishing
prisons would be a good idea it's not a
large percentage
it's not a large percentage of black
people it's not a large percentage
of anything what it is is contagious
and so the the question is not
how many people will say black lives
matter
therefore these downstream consequences
because those people are rationalizing
their own participation in a ponzi
scheme
right and you can actually see this in
the history of ponzi schemes
the initial ponzi scheme involves stamps
then there was a bunch of pyramid
schemes you and i remember as kids
that there was this pond this uh pyramid
scheme
moment where the fbi started busting
pyramid schemes
and you know it was like the late 70s
early 80s yeah i think it was 70s it was
and there was all of this footage of
like these
uh you know rooms full of card tables
people had rented these spaces
for their for their uh um pyramid
schemes
and people were marched out in handcuffs
and all of this stuff and then there was
this next phase which was the
multi-level
marketing version where instead of just
having a pure pyramid scheme you
pretended it was about a product
right and so anyway this is not the
house of cards has something inside of
it
right you're selling some object rather
than selling an opportunity to
participate in a
pyramid scheme right so that you can
rationalize that this is really about
knives or water filters or whatever the
hell
was because products yeah right beauty
products um
so now we're in a new phase and that's
kind of the point here is the new phase
is there's no product there is a
message that is being carried forward
and that message is structured
so everybody can sign on right
if you can't sign on to black lives
matter there's something wrong with you
and i actually agree with that
at the slogan level yeah black lives are
undervalued
anybody should be able to sign on to
that but having signed on to it
what have you dragged in with you you've
dragged in all of these nonsense
proposals these civilization ending
proposals
right which you can disavow you can say
oh no but you know i got attacked on
twitter
you know nobody is saying abolish the
police really i can read in the new york
times right
it's right there but you can tell
yourself what abolish the police means
is
defund which means reduce the
militarization yada yada all of the
rationalizations so but you see on
on the official black lives website
which is the one thing that they have
given to uh you know those of us who
would like to make them
accountable for what they're doing right
um you
you see as we've talked about in past
livestreams them going after the nuclear
family them
conflating trans black lives with all
black lives and right you know rising in
the ranks
um trans lives you know over over all
sorts of other lives
uh you see official black lives matter
accounts going after israel so you know
in what way is anti-semitism
about black lives matter and what in
what way are trans lives about black
lives matter in what way is the nuclear
family
an attack on black lives matter i mean
really i mean that's that's the
most obvious one to say what are you
guys doing right
yeah it it's preposterous but okay let's
go to the next phase so you've got
absolute nonsense arguments
you've got policy which is moving at an
incredible rate
like seattle is now playing with the
most
dangerous moves based on the idea that
there is public outcry demanding these
things when that public outcry is itself
based in part on fear and in part on a
pyramid scheme
and there's no way i mean we are
literally not supposed to be making
policy on the basis
of people being violent in the street
right right
and yet that's what we're about to do
and it it um
it looks very much like uh teleb's point
about the tiniest minority being able to
drive
policy which is absolutely undemocratic
um do you want to show this letter that
emerged yesterday yeah so this
before you show it zach i think we need
to set it up a little bit i think in
mid-june
the seattle city council voted
unanimously
uh in a uh let's see city council
ordinance 119 805
um to actually you can show it now
exactly
to ban seattle police officers from
using
less lethal tools including pepper spray
um karen's bands
yep uh and what and that goes into
effect tomorrow
so that was voted on unanimously so that
does suggest that
either the tiny minority is all in power
or it's now becoming or
or this fear this mechanism of fear the
stick motivator
has caused people to fall in line voted
on in mid-june
goes into effect tomorrow and so the
police chief in seattle sent a letter to
dear to business owners and residents of
seattle yesterday
effectively saying we are going to be
deploying police differently and less
when we get calls because
basically because we cannot um we cannot
keep ourselves
safe and the way that we would want to
have before
and this is you know the letter
specifically says
we are not going to um we are not going
to put ourselves in harm's way
to defend property it does not say we
are not going to put ourselves in harm's
way to defend
you if you are under duress but um but
that that point looks like a slippery
slope oh well it's clearly a slippery
slope and there are
two blocks in portland where the police
will not defend you
if things happen to you this has now
been demonstrated
uh on video now there are times of day
when it's perfectly safe to go there but
there are times of day when it is
reliably not the police know exactly
where this is and they
i think can't intervene based on the
constraints that they've been handed by
city government so um
yes we are not yet at the position of
the police
failing to defend people in a general
sense across the city
there are places in cities where that's
true
but it is not yet general but the rate
at which we are moving in this direction
is absolutely staggering and as
a result of the phony impression that
this is what the public is demanding
right so maybe uh
let's talk a little bit about the
portland situation so um
can we do that slideshow zach i took
some
pictures and i don't know what order
they're in but it almost doesn't matter
actually can you start with the um
can you start with the um image from
reddit of the notice that was posted on
the fence
okay so what you have now for those of
you who are listening
is a removal notice for the fence that
has been placed in front
of the courthouse this is the city
government
placing a notice on the fence that is
used to protect
the courthouse from nightly incursions
by
the protesters let me be clear the fence
was erected by
federal officers and the city of
portland this
the portland bureau of transportation is
declaring that the fence that was
erected by federal officers
is a hazard and must be removed it's a
hazard but the but the fence was erected
by federal officers that's the piece i
didn't hear you
so the federal officers have been left
to defend these buildings because the
city is not enforcing the law
so the federal officers are defending
the buildings and instead of defending
them
against incursions that come right up
into
break into the building start fires all
of this stuff they put up a fence
to reduce the access of these nightly
riders
the city is now saying oh you're
blocking traffic which is actually
nonsense
it is true that they do come into a lane
of traffic but it's not like the traffic
doesn't move it moves perfectly well
but the city is now effectively signing
up with the rioters to get the fence
removed the rioters try to remove the
fence every night and they frequently
succeed
so the city has now uh taken a position
on these riots
um okay now do you want to go through
the slideshow
these are slides that you took uh these
are pictures that you took this morning
yeah
these are pictures i took this morning
so here things are calm
absolutely calm which is a reliable fact
they are calm every day
uh during daylight hours this is in the
park directly across
from the uh courthouse
this is a concession stand in which you
can get
free ribs they've named it riot ribs
which is funny
but nonetheless this is an autonomous
zone okay it's undeclared but it clearly
is an autonomous zone
these concession stands are there every
day okay can you advance one
here are city workers cleaning up the
nightly mayhem hey zach we can't tell
which
you're showing us two different pictures
we don't know what people can see at the
moment
okay can you go one more
okay here you see a huge number of
barbecues okay this is absolutely an
autonomous zone these
barbecues are there they're being used
to cook
food keep going
okay that one is not in the correct
orientation but you can still read that
it says
get out of my city feds go home now
remember the rioters nightly attack
federal buildings
and the police the local police are not
enforcing the law
therefore i would argue that actually
the feds have no
choice but to defend those buildings i
mean legally speaking they have no
choice
and so in effect we are being set up to
imagine
that there is a federal incurs now there
are things about the way that
the um these this influx of federal
officers is going about their business
that make me uncomfortable
but it's also not as portrayed they are
taking people into unmarked cars but
they themselves are clearly labeled
as federal officers um
and so more pictures yep keep going
this one says there's no police force
like no
police force so when people tell you
that nobody is arguing for no police
force
in fact it's right here on this tree
keep going okay
our mayor our mayor is being taunted by
these people
right ted squealer and he's depicted as
a pig and of course
pig means cop to these people above it
is a sticker that says gas me teddy now
i want to talk a little bit about this
term
gas right the term gas is being used to
make everybody squeamish
about tear gas now i don't like the idea
that tear gas is being used in portland
but the thing is tear gas
is an irritant right the term gas
evokes mustard gas it uh evokes
nazi gas chambers and zyklon b
so the point is the idea that ted
wheeler is
gassing people is being used
to make him squeamish about doing what
he absolutely must do
as the mayor and police commissioner
which is enforced the law which he is
not doing
um let's see the final sticker here says
uh talk to plants
talk to plants not cops now this is all
very
humorous except that um this don't
talk to cops thing is being used to make
a an incident a violent incident between
the police and the protesters slash
rioters
more likely it's divisive it is
dehumanizing
uh we saw the uh
bits of this during occupy of course
it was considered treason to talk to the
cops even though it is necessary to talk
to them
frankly they are citizens too and it is
necessary that they understand that they
are not
up against some monolith but that they
are up against people i believe that you
had a conversation
with a policeman uh during occupy
in olympia in which you
talked to him and i think maybe even a
couple other of other policemen uh
came around and were engaging about
the need to not follow orders when
orders are themselves immoral
in moral order this is the conversation
that you were having with police and you
were being decried
by fellow protesters for engaging with
police yeah and that was a peaceful
protest that was a place
um but you know that was actually you
know when we were being told to get off
the lawn so we didn't hurt the lawn
right like this that that was that was
what this is pretending to be
yep it is pretending and that is
uh from the point of view of the new
york times and all of your standard
democratic outlets the portrayal
makes one move right the idea is this is
all
a reaction to a federal incursion
therefore
this is effectively trump deploying
troops to the streets of portland
because we always
were told that he was going to do this
this he was it was going to be a power
grab but the fact is
no no there were federal officers
defending these buildings because that's
legally required they are federal
buildings
and then the surge of new uh federal
cops
is the result of the fact that these
city cops aren't doing their job
yeah i should point out the notice
saying that the fence was impeding
traffic and therefore had to go
is actually part of a deeper plan i am
told you are told by whom
well there were two people who had a
sign out
saying that they were offering free
legal advice to people who had been
released from
jail after having been arrested in the
circle people
on a portland near in downtown portland
early on a saturday
when there is no activity really but you
know patently sympathetic to the
protesters and
no evidence that they themselves are you
know adding to the chaos or the anarchy
nope i would say these people
looked like they were probably folks who
knew what they were talking about
legally probably had been to law school
don't know but okay so what did they say
to you they said to me
that um the fence was impeding traffic
where it was
but to move it back towards the building
would violate the americans with
disabilities act
so effectively they've got the feds
right where they want them
oh god um well
the the americans with disabilities are
needing to go
inside the federal like like what i mean
what is the access that is
that's apparently the access but i mean
but but
okay yeah i mean i i don't i just don't
even know it's hard
it's hard to counter the argument
because i mean presumably
you and i would both want americans with
disabilities to be able to access this
building on the other hand
i don't want well they blocked a bike
lane earlier and i know we bike and we
don't want bike lanes blocked but
but for god's sake so here's the thing
if you're going to argue that this
federal incursion
is illegitimate then it is your
obligation to explain what is supposed
to be happening because it looks to me
like they have gone up against every
tier and the last tier the only tier
that won't give
are the feds right i don't like that
that's not what's supposed to be going
on in downtown portland
but if the city is going to abdicate
responsibility and they're going to
attack a federal building which
obviously they are doing to precipitate
a federal response
you get rid of these smaller more local
more empathetic to your particular
phenomenon
hometown police and what you will get is
a police state
this is what will happen and that's not
what i think is that doesn't appear to
be
the goal by anyone here but this will be
the effect
of going after the smaller jurisdiction
policing which is happening not just in
seattle and portland but in lots of
places
so let's talk a little bit about the are
there more slides there zach
you want to go through the remainder of
them and then i'd like to talk about the
the next level here end the police
occupation of portland
i don't see that the police are occupied
portland i see
that rioters are occupying portland
i mean we've got effectively two months
of nightly
riots against federal buildings
so this is a false narrative that this
is the police occupying portland and it
implies of course if the police leave
everything will be hunky-dory
when effectively we can see that the
people who are demanding this
are attempting to light these buildings
on fire should we allow that
right okay keep going
trump nazis go to hell okay now this
i think is the crux of it is
that we have a situation in which
the fact of trump in the white house
and the fact therefore that everything
federal looks
to people on the left like trump
means that there is
a total loss of coherence
right more slides
so here you can see this is clearly an
undeclared autonomous zone
right these are this these are
concession stands set up
in a public park across the street from
this courthouse where nightly there are
riots
it's clearly an autonomous zone anymore
here is where uh rioters have
attempted to cut through the barricade
there are many of these breaches
and it is not difficult online to find
video of the protesters shaking the
fence
down ripping it apart on a regular basis
anything else ah this is actually part
and parcel of what we were talking about
before this model in which the messages
are being evolved online
okay here's a hashtag spray painted tear
gas
ted yeah okay tear gas
ted keep going
okay all cops are bastards no justice no
peace
and that that bit of graffiti on the far
end says
[ __ ] you which in some sense i think may
be
the best description of what this means
here we see
on the justice center abolish usa
now you know be wonderful how many of
these people have ever been outside of
this country
i i mean this is this has been my my
point for months now
i mean years actually because we saw yes
we saw this at evergreen
that the the most susceptible to this
batshit ideology were the people with
the most naivete about what the world
actually looks like what different
people
sound like and and think like and eat
like
and what their music is and what it is
to be on the ground in someone else's
culture
abolish the usa try going somewhere else
and living with other people for a while
in the conditions in which they live
and come back to your home
and let's talk then well even then
even that i mean i agree with you that
you know
it's not people who have seen the world
who are arguing to abolish the usa but
even that those other countries are
stable
if you abolish the usa so i've heard
recently what does the world look like
where you've abolished the police
right it looks like a beautiful white
suburb
no it doesn't right it does not this is
the same people who believe in noble
savages
frankly it's the same level of analysis
it is
utopian nonsense it's nonsense and the
thing is it looks like
you know mogadishu right or
what not so it does not look like uh bel
air it looks like mogadishu it looks
like
right it looks like you know war-torn
afghanistan
right the point is and a power vacuum
does not
serve the downtrodden it serves those
who are
amoral and willing to wield violence in
their own
uh interests and that's what we saw in
the one official autonomous zone that
was established
in seattle the jazz chop before it was
actually disbanded by the seattle police
when they still did have some power to
do so which may
you know which may stop tomorrow uh that
no it didn't it wasn't all roses and
unicorns people
no it's nonsense and the fact is we
should not have to test this on
civilization
in order to discover what kind of
nonsense it is because frankly
um you don't need to be that smart to
extrapolate to what actually happens
when you tear the structure down that is
keeping the peace
well i think once again i've used this
phrase before but i think it's the comic
bookification
of uh people's moral sense that they
think that there are
true heroes who do nothing but good in
the world
and there are true villains who do
nothing but evil in the world
and i think people have also slaughtered
every single other human being into
well they may not rise to having a cape
but they're actually all heroes so we've
got
a whole bunch of people who simply do
good in the world and then a few people
who simply do evil and if we just get
rid of the evil
then we'll be fine it's like these
people have never spent a moment alone
with themselves
themselves every single one of us has
thoughts
and proclivities that aren't as
honorable as they might be every
single one of us and the idea that you
can imagine
that a vast majority of humans are
purely good
begins with the idea that you can
imagine that a single human being can be
purely good and frankly this is part of
this is part of the same ridiculous
foundational belief that gets us to
actually to use another uh television
uh what he calls retrospective
bigoteering okay so this is the idea
that um all we have to do is find
something in
important historical figures past um
that uh rendered them a bigot or somehow
not pure by today's standards and we can
cancel them
right so this actually let me see if i
can pull up his actual language because
it's good
um here we go zach
um accusing ancient individuals or
groups of violating today's ethical
norms
saying aristotle was sexist or nietzsche
was racist should only be used in what
probabilistics call filtration at time t
okay i'm not going to read the whole
television here
he does say let me see i think i can get
to the whole tweet here he points out
the new york times suggests
cancelling aristotle this is
retrospective bigoteering it implies
that moral values do
not evolve which we know they do people
need to be judged with respect to the
morals of their own time
but this is the important thing
parenthetical and teles tweet but we can
be harsh with napoleon
because he reinstated slavery the this
is what we need to be doing
looking at when people actually were
regressive for their own time
made decisions that were that were that
were bad in their own time
or on the contrary were perhaps
forward-thinking and progressive and
moving towards greater unity and less
division
for a number of people in their own time
even if
they simultaneously did things that were
of the norm
of their time that would not be regarded
as honorable by today's standards
and frankly even in the case
when they were regressive for their own
time right
uh unfortunately i don't have the uh the
evidence for it ready to display but i
saw
an important uh move
at the highest levels to remove the
names
of uh important scientific figures
because of their own
moral failings fischer that's this
that's this retrospective bigoteering
this is exactly what telepath is talking
about but here's my feeling
look we are evolutionary biologists r.a
fisher
was deeply anti-semitic
okay i don't want r.a fisher removed
from biological history because it will
set us back
70 years right well i mean it's just
it's not even possible
right right i mean not only not not only
are his thinkings uh completely embedded
in evolutionary theory he's also by many
measures the father of modern statistics
that's exactly it not only is he the guy
who figured out
sex ratios which are the basis for
understanding all sorts of important
phenomena
including why men and women are
different and meaningfully so
but the father of modern statistics yes
was he morally compromised yes likewise
did he have some reprehensible ideas
yes too bad likewise con conrad lorenz
um you know and if we want to you know
go after darwin louis agassi and
like uh pretty much anyone from more
than 100 years ago is going to have held
some beliefs that we in retrospect can
say
no i wish you didn't i wish you hadn't
right but the thing is
history is what it is and so the thing
is i'm not looking to obscure
what was wrong with these people's
beliefs systems i don't want you know
the idea that
fisher was anti-semitic eliminated from
his wikipedia page i want that front and
center so people understand that
somebody who was morally compromised was
nonetheless
clear-headed in a way that's so
important we still invoke him regularly
today
right so certainly we can
retrospectively
forgive him his sins if he did not
uh if he did not act on them in ways
that
did damage to people and we can
appreciate
what he did bring to our understanding
of the world i think the thing is
history it's got to be warts and all but
you can't obscure it
tearing you know tearing down george
washington does nobody any good that's
right um but so i want to
sort of bring this full circle part of
what is going on
on uh the left side of the spectrum
is that the shadow cast by trump is so
big that it has blinded the entire left
to
its own failings and this
is going to actually wreck the us
and because of the role that the u.s
plays internationally
the danger is quite a bit beyond that
right
as long as trump is in the white house
people on the left
cannot understand that they actually
have to balance concerns and you will
actually hear people say this
right why are you focused on x when we
still have this primary problem
well i have yet to hear anybody
apologize for telling me he was hitler
right i have yet to hear anybody say
actually we were wrong about that but
still right it's like that never
happened right that was
regularly claimed i haven't heard it
well and it's well it's still implied in
one of those pictures you showed the
trump nazis right
yep it's still implied on that
particular tree but nonetheless in
polite circles it's
rarely invoked anymore so the idea is
you'll still still hear fascist
yeah right but hitler i haven't heard
that one except from that tree
recently right so you are talking to the
plants
you took the advice of that other sign
no i will talk to the cops
and i will also talk to the plants but
the plants talk to you
i'm listening and the right plants i'm
all ears or eyes i said it as
it is but but in any case yeah look
people
the problem isn't trump okay the problem
is the
confluence of trump and the reaction
that thing is putting civilization in
jeopardy right
and it is not uh
it is not reasonable it is not smart it
is not
uh logically defensible to
behave in this way to tear down the
structures that we are now
jeopardizing simply because you
find the guy in the white house
abhorrent
and likewise as many people have pointed
out the fact that you find him abhorrent
doesn't mean
that he's wrong on every issue and
you know it's your responsibility to
explain what is supposed to happen
especially here in the pacific northwest
when you have
um rioters clearly attempting to
precipitate
a federal response you have the new york
times
portraying uh trump as the instigator
when in fact in this case
he is at the very least he is responding
to two months of
riots you know so um
anyway can we please get over this sense
that um just because trump is in the
white house you're allowed to do
anything say anything
attack anything because that can't
possibly be right
that's right two last things yep
uh to to pick up tele again for the
third time today
uh in the piece where he originally
writes about bigoteering and then
alludes to this
uh what he calls retrospective
bigoteering he also introduces a
term called that he calls pedophrasti so
you can put this up if you will zach
and pedophrasti he says his definition
is an argument involving children to
prop up a rationalization and make the
opponent look like an [ __ ]
as people are defenseless and suspend
all skepticism in front of suffering
children nobody has the heart to
question the authenticity or source of
the reporting
often done with the aid of pictures
we've all seen this
but in the current moment i would add to
this
matra frasty the wall of moms in
portland
is if it is legitimate at all it is this
it is it is matra frasty uh which you
know it's not a word any more than peter
frasty was before teleb coined it but
i'm now coining
matrifrasti which to use exactly his
definition for children
an argument involving mothers to proper
rationalization to make the opponent
look like an
[ __ ] as people are defenseless and
suspend all skepticism in front of the
suffering mothers
nobody has the heart to question the
authenticity or source of the reporting
often done with the aid of pictures uh
totally agree with this now as you know
i've um
done a little uh attending of the
um the protests and i will say i have
attended the protest because the
protests
um precede the riots and i've been
warned and i've now seen
reason to think it's true that attending
within each day you're talking about
temporally yes
the protests happen and then the sun
sets and then the right there's a
protest rally that happens and then
violence breaks out tear gas is used
those these things
um but i saw the wall of moms
uh i would say
maybe 20 percent of them appear old
enough to
be moms i'm not saying they're not
biologically old enough but they did not
read as a wall of moms they
read as a wall of yellow shirts now
interestingly
as i left uh to go
home the the day that i intersected with
the
wall of moms i did see some people who
were almost
certainly mothers walking towards
in yellow shirts so i'm not arguing that
there are no mothers among them
but i'm arguing that this is actually
taking a small number of mothers and
turning them into an
outcry of mothers in order for the new
york times
to to rant and rail against trump's
fascist incursion into portland
and it doesn't read that way on the
ground it really doesn't and so
um had it i'd be telling you but it
doesn't
and i'm not saying actually this is
maybe the the
most difficult part for me the rally
that preceded
the riots the the night that i
encountered the wall of moms
was electric okay by which you mean what
by which i meant um you could
feel the camaraderie in the air right
and you know i think what they're
demanding is nonsense
i think that you know a rally preceding
a predictable riot in which
people are attacking federal buildings
attacking elk statues
occupying city blocks that this
is completely unacceptable but as
somebody with experience in the world
i'm telling you
the moms didn't look organic to me but
the sense of camaraderie
was there it was in the air enough that
somebody who is as skeptical as i am of
this
still felt it walking into that and that
should tell you something
yeah well among other things apparently
we're supposed to talk to the plants but
not to the elk
right well exactly because what do elk
eat
they eat plants right we're on the side
of the plants and the angels
okay to finish this off i'd like to read
a few paragraphs from
a uh a op-ed i guess published in the
boston globe
actually a week and a half ago by robbie
george and cornell west
robbie george is a friend of ours and uh
robbie george
who is conservative in cornell west who
is a liberal
um are fast friends as well and they are
sort of the i don't know if poster
children is the right term but
for um for working across and friending
across significant differences and
actually
seeing the value and honor in other
people's positions so they've written a
piece called
to unite the country we need honesty and
courage uh you can show it briefly
although then i'm going to go back to my
screen because i want to read just bits
and pieces of it
so it begins oh okay
it begins fellow citizens honesty and
courage alone can save our wounded
disunited country now
we need the honesty and courage to speak
the truth including painful truths that
unsettled not only our foes but also our
friends and most especially ourselves
and it's a it's a long and wonderful
piece um in the middle of it
there are these six short paragraphs
we need the honesty and courage not to
compromise our beliefs or go silent on
them out of a desire to be accepted or
out of fear of being ostracized excluded
or cancelled
we need the honesty and courage to
consider with an open mind and heart
points of view that challenge our
beliefs
even our deepest most cherished identity
forming beliefs
we need the intellectual humility to
recognize our own fallibility and that
too requires honesty and courage we need
the honesty and courage to recognize and
acknowledge that there are reasonable
people of good will who do not share
even some of our deepest most cherished
beliefs
this is true for christians like
ourselves or members of other traditions
of faith as well as for religious
skeptics and atheists
it is true for conservatives as well as
progressives for libertarians as well as
socialists
we need the honesty and courage to treat
decent and honest people with whom we
disagree
even on the most consequential questions
as partners in truth-seeking and fellow
citizens of our republican order
not as enemies to be destroyed and we
must always respect and protect their
human rights and civil liberties
we need honesty and courage to be
willing to change our beliefs and
stances if evidence
reason and compelling argument persuade
us that they are in need of revision
even at the cost of alienating us from
communities in which we are comfortable
and rely on for personal affirmation
solidarity and support and finally
we need the honesty and courage to love
in the highest and best sense
to will the good of the other for the
sake of the other to treat even our
adversaries as precious members of the
human family
we need the honesty and courage to
resist the hatred the spirit of hatred
that the zeal even for good causes can
induce and we frail
fallen fallible human beings and that
corrupts the human soul
and leads inexorably to spiritual
emptiness and to tyranny
even among those who began as sincere
advocates of freedom
and justice so
this is marvelous and fits perfectly
with
uh the guy we have come to know robbie
george is a
truly amazing human being who has come
to our defense many times despite being
on the other side of the political
spectrum from us
i think there are two things that we
need to add to cap this off
though i will try to keep them brief
first one zach could you show that
tweet that i sent you here's what
happens if we
well what zack is looking for is
a tweet that um
yep
can you put it on the big screen so we
can read it
okay the tweet and i said i must tell
you i wish i could just simply
assume that the i know that the event is
real i cannot vouch for the source i
know nothing about them they may
they are more than likely just fine but
i don't know enough about the source
to to say but the tweet says good
morning from louisville kentucky
today an all-black militia group called
the not [ __ ] around coalition hashtag
nfac is holding an armed rally
for briana taylor expected at noon
conservative militias are already
gathering to counter it
i'll be covering all day so this is
happening
uh i don't know if the images are
necessary or not
the fact of this rally is significant
i have seen uh video of the rally itself
i have seen
video of the militias that are coming
to counter-protest it i know that at
least one shot was fired probably
accidentally
nonetheless the danger to the republic
that comes from not listening
to cornell west and robbie george is
spectacular
and immediate and that is what we are
playing with
is that this will unfold badly one bad
confrontation
between one group and another that gets
read
as somehow an attack
uh is or is an attack a single
entity that decides to make an attack
could set things in a direction from
which we will not recover and we must
not allow that to happen
yeah okay final thing
um with the death of michael brooks i
have held my fire
with respect to the um interaction
with the producer of the majority report
matt lech
but there's something that needs to be
said here so many will
remember that matt lech unleashed a
falsehood about me and therefore
about us that i was somehow consulting
for the department of homeland security
and what he was
referring to was discussion with
a an officer for the dhs which i didn't
i made no secret of i talked about it
right here on the live stream so he took
that and he portrayed it
as my um consulting
for the department of homeland security
and then i said that he needed to
apologize he needed to retract and he
needed to be fired
and i was challenged in a way that i
actually probably should have seen
coming but i did not expect
which is oh i get it you are in favor of
cancel culture
when it's about you now this strikes me
as
insane why does matt letch need to be
fired
he does not need to be canceled i never
wanted him canceled he needs to be
fired for cause that's what used to
happen in the adult world
when somebody if your pilot shows up
drunk
they need to be fired for cause if your
surgeon
refuses to scrub up before surgery they
need to be fired
for cause that's not cancellation this
person does not belong in journalism
and if he just made an error if this is
once in a lifetime
then he needs to own up to that error
exactly and nothing he has delivered so
far is anything other than grudging so
i think he needs to be fired for cause
and i think sam cedar needs to
understand that his ability to continue
in whatever he's doing if it's
journalism requires
that he own up to the fact that what
match matt ledge did
is uh justification for firing and that
that is actually the required action
unless something
utterly extraordinary happens so i don't
want to hear any more of this garbage
about i'm for cancel culture this has
nothing to do with cancer culture
this has to do with the fact that the
world functions when people do jobs
properly and some jobs
uh do not accept failures like this a
drunk pilot needs to be fired for cause
a journalist who lies about
the nature of an interaction of citizens
with federal
officers needs to be fired for cause why
because it put us in danger there are
nightly attacks on federal officers
in portland violent attacks by
describing
us as collaborating with the department
of homeland security
that was clearly painting a target on us
that was
foreseeably going to end in violence
against us on
totally false pretenses so anyway i now
feel
that issue is clear enough and if you
describe it as cancel culture that's
your failure
all right okay well i think we
are uh about ready to wrap up yep
tomorrow we will have our private q
a uh for darkhorse members uh for people
at
my patreon at the five dollar or up
level
uh at 11 am
if you're interested in the private
discord server
uh you can find you can access that by
joining either of our patreons at the
five dollar up level
what else is clips channel clips channel
unity 20 20. there's unity 2020. um
big things are headed your way keep your
eye out for that
um you just released the zoobee
conversation yes yes zoomy conversation
i was just gonna say
zoomy conversation is great zubi is a
gem and totally worth your time so you
should check that out
if you haven't seen the matt taibi
discussion that one also uh
so excellent yeah um
mike mew the black english foreign table
it's uh it's all good this guy knows
what he's doing
all right uh so we are going to return
yeah so we'll we'll take a 15-minute
break we'll
we will be answering as many of your
super chat questions as we can
taking uh the top uh
monetary value ones from this first hour
first and then
uh taking what comes in next hour in
roughly the order in which they come in
looking forward to doing so yep uh so
uh tune in to the q a and we'll see you
shortly
you